what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so as we continue our series on too
powerful for Marvel movies in this video
I want to focus on Legion on David
holler because in reality he is crazy
powerful I mean it's and it's he's he's
powerful for a reason that you probably
don't expect so when it comes to when it
comes to David holler he's the son of
Charles Xavier and Gabriel holler and
the way this worked was I gave you a
holler was working in Israel at the time
and she was essentially a doctor in a
ward that helped people who were
basically dealing with like the
Holocaust and what ended up happening is
Charles Xavier was using his powers to
kind of help people overcome that and
like a romance blossom between the two
and they basically had an affair and
then David was born the issue with this
was that in the beginning David never
had there was no indication that David
had powers and in fact Xavier didn't
even know that that David existed but
David gave no indication he had any
abilities whatsoever you know no
telepathy telekinesis or none of that
stuff but all that changed when he and
his mom were the victims of like a
terrorist attack there's this guy named
named gemayel Komori who leads this like
rogue faction as this this you know
terrorist group that launches an attack
and in the aftermath of it all David
incinerates them Ryan Lee he kills every
single person there and in the process
he absorbs the mind of Jamel kumari and
what this does is it basically gives
David the ability to tap into telepathy
essentially he basically like absorbs
Jamil Kumari's personality develops
telepathy in the process and then goes
forward starting to starting develop
like decent multiple personalities
because the trauma of the event was
never properly dealt with and so over
the years and Marvel Comics David's
David's multiple personalities it was
kind of multiplied over and over and
over again and that's the reason why
he's probably the single most powerful
character in Marvel Comics is because
David himself doesn't really have a
whole and doesn't really have much to
speak of it's all the personalities that
he has david has thousands of
personalities in his head each one
having it having a power now sometimes
these powers are identical you have
characters out there who who can you
know who give him like telepathy right
you know and then like he might have
like 50 or like 500 personalities all of
which have telepathy but they all have
their own distinct personality and so
when they take over who knows what's
gonna happen maybe they're benign maybe
they're just downright evil like sticks
for example was like a super evil
personality of David odde that you
control masses like masses of people
using telepathy but could also cast
illusions and then had like a soul
stealing touch like where if you touched
you he would steal your soul from your
body
so like there were there were crazy
powers that were there but like some of
them oh really a lot of them were pretty
exotic but to give you guys perspective
on how wild these powers were so you had
a guy named Wolfman personality called
Wolfman which had a healing factor that
was superior to both Wolverine and
Deadpool so literally like like he
healed faster and better than both
Wolverine and Deadpool did which if
you're not familiar with that Deadpool
is largely considered to have the best
healing factor at least outside of
Legion Deadpool is considered to have
like the best healing factor in Marvel
Comics right like it's more efficient
and is faster than Wolverines you have a
character named name more akin Ross and
more akin Ross was a character who
debuted an age of action agent X itself
was really a story that kind of like
showcased how powerful the personalities
of Legion worked so what ended up
happening in age of X is just like one
day people wake up like the world wakes
up and things are starkly different you
know like like really it's all kind of
confined on an island there's a handful
of x-men there and they're constantly
battling like the Avengers and things
like that or at least what would be the
Avengers team it's kind of disheveled
essentially battling humanity but they
never leave the building
and come to find out what had happened
was one of the personalities of Legion
more akin Roth had basically more
Kinross rather had basically like
rewritten existence and warped reality
in its entirety now in reality is kind
of confined to a localized space and so
it's really one of those assumptions
that more akin Roth's can alter the
entire fabric of reality but we don't
really know because in the Age of X
timeline and in the Age of X story we
didn't really see anything outside of
Earth for the most part we just kind of
saw things confined to earth in this
small localized space so it could be
that she's just like Proteus right where
she like you know warps or manipulates
reality and like a small radius of like
50 feet or like like 50 miles or
something along those lines but she
can't like alter the entire fabric of
the universe like Scarlet Witch during a
house of him really Scarlet Witch and
like she she altered the fabric of the
multiverse like she changed she wiped
out 90% of the mutant populations powers
in the entire multiverse as opposed to
just one single universe but you've got
characters like Susan and sunshine who
can feed on people's emotions and then
turn them into an actual energy you've
got endgame who actually adapts to
people's powers you've got the origamist
who can fold space and reality like
literally space and time can like fold
it all in and turn it into whatever he
wants I mean you've got like all these
wild and exotic personalities here and
that's what makes Legion so dangerous is
because oftentimes David doesn't even
like David doesn't really have control
these powers that was the whole idea
behind the aftermath of Age of X like
Age of X happens and then it gets fixed
like okay we have to figure out what's
going on and then you end up finding out
that like somewhere along the line all
of legions power all of leaders
personalities have basically broken free
so inside his mind we had this kind of
compartmentalization where these
personalities were kept in check and he
could kind of pick and choose which ones
he wanted to take out all those all the
prison gates were open as all the
personalities were just like running
amuck it's all like one moment he would
be jaja male Kumari the next moment he
would be Cindy the next moment he would
be Jack Wayne the moment after that he
would be in-game and after that he'd be
Susan in SunShot he would just start
bouncing around through all these
different personalities and all this
kind of stuff that in and of itself is
why Legion is too powerful for the MCU
is because but wouldn't when it comes to
character that we've talked about so far
we've talked about characters that are
largely self-contained right so you have
like this century or the void whichever
one you want talked about you've got
like Franklin Richards or you've got
like the molecule man Owen Reese and
they're very powerful in their own right
but they're powerful insofar as they are
a singular person with a singular
personality who has a singular power
with Legion you don't know who you'd be
facing off against you have no idea what
version of that character you would be
fighting and so if your iron man you
know in in Legion pops up and suddenly
he has one of his personalities that
lets him control fire then like he
literally just like starts spewing all
this fire at you and like he's uh he's
bent on destroying the world and there's
nothing you can do it depends on what
version of Legion you're facing off
against so because that he's way too
powerful because looking at someone like
like Thanos with the Infinity Gauntlet
for example right you know and then the
movie Santos has the Infinity Gauntlet
he uses it for his own purposes you know
and Blake's out half a life in the
universe or something like that like
that's controlling reality you know
across the universe wiping out half the
half of the existence with someone like
like more akin Ross she could just come
back and bring it all back she used to
be like okay and we're done like we're
just gonna restore half the life of the
universe and she could do that on her
own just rewrite existence in its
entirety like rewrite past and like like
the past and the present completely
assuming that she's able to function on
a multiversal space so again it's a it's
a very dangerous game when it comes to
his character because for David one of
the things that makes him crazy as a
factory hat or one thing to make some
dangers is the fact that he has good
intentions but goes about it the wrong
way like a really good example is is
legion quest the lead into Age of
Apocalypse those guys who don't know
durin during Legion quest there was a
point where mystique had sought to kill
David because David he killed her lover
destiny and the result was that when
when she went to go like wake him up out
of a comatose state that he basically
like imprison her like he's shut her
down entirely and was like I'm gonna fix
everything and so what he does is he
ends up travelling over to traveling
into the past and then his idea is to
kill magneto before he can rise to
become like a mutant terrorist basically
and his his whole goal here is if
magneto doesn't exist that it'll make
the life of Charles Xavier a lot easier
in terms of trying to form a peaceful
coexistence between humans of mutants
because of the time magneto was very
much like a bad guy he was very much you
know just kind of yeah yet like his
acolytes and all that kind of stuff and
like asteroid am or Providence or
whatever you want to call it he had like
all those things going on but the idea
was that Legion wanted to like destroy
magneto before he could rise to become
Magneto the issue was that when that
happened Charles Xavier jumped in the
way the killing blow in Charles Xavier
died and so at the moment that happened
the villain apocalypse who is watching
the entire event unfold chose that as
his moment to launch his campaign for
world domination and took over the
entirety of North America and because
magneto was nowhere near as effective of
an x-men leader as Charles Xavier was
what ended up happening is as magneto
tried to create an x-men team of sorts
but ultimately it was like a ragtag team
it was really more of like guerrilla
warfare tactics and so on and it all
kind of went belly up until the very end
when they were all saved by like Bishop
you know and and like the the m'kraan
crystal I think it was but nonetheless
you know it's pretty wild when it comes
to a character of that level of power
because again all these personalities
are all have distinct abilities and some
of them are very very basic telepathy
telekinesis controlling fire creating
fire things like that all the way up to
the higher echelons of characters who
can warp reality on unlike a universal
scale it's one reasons why Legion is so
powerful he's a he's a cosmic level
threat so again like like when you're
talking about the economic are you
talking about the Avengers there's no
way they could stand against a person
with that kind of power because in
reality like like he could he could
switch their personalities so fast that
they wouldn't be able to keep up I mean
Doctor Strange would be the most likely
person to be able to defeat Legion but
even then there's no guarantee because
even Doctor Strange his powers in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe are fairly
limited in comparison to his version in
like Marvel Comics he's pretty weak you
know all that goes into the idea that
the MCU is designed to make the
characters more grounded and so if what
you've got in Doctor Strange in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe was like the
1970s coming book counterpart it'd be
ridiculous like people would just be
like well then just send in Doctor
Strange because you'll fix everything
because you can do anything he wants to
alter reality you know time travel or
like jump from dimension to dimension or
whatever the case is you know so you got
to kind of tone them down in order to
make the stories believable but even
then assuming that you even-toned Legion
down for the MCU still I mean you're
talking about a guy with
thousands of personalities each one
having having their own power their own
Lily their own motives motivations their
own ideas you know they're the basis
behind why they exist and then
functioning accordingly and then
literally unleashing absolute
pandemonium on the MCU so it would be
kind of interesting to see how that
unfolds but again there's there's no
real contest here I mean at the end of
the day it's just the Avengers trying to
fight god and it's just not really gonna
work out but with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb core
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]